bueno buenas noches muchas gracias en
realidad la estrategia no se la conoce
ese es una de las principales críticas
que hemos dicho desde la academia
parecería ser que responde a que el
primer nivel de atención de salud son
los primeros que se deberían beneficiar
de la vacuna pero hemos visto que ha
existido desorganización y no han
existido planes claros de priorización
de las vacunas de entendemos que como
8.000 vacunas que actualmente están en
el país la priorización debería
responder a necesidades en base a
vulnerabilidades el más vulnerable se
vacunaría primero dentro del grupo de
los más vulnerables que son el personal
de salud no y eso aparentemente no ha
pasado actualmente el personal sanitario
pues se ha visto desplegado en varias
áreas porque por ejemplo los médicos
rurales están exigiendo su vacunación y
su justa vacunación pero a la vez
también los médicos residentes están
exigiendo la firma de sus contratos que
aparentemente se los y promocionó pero
nunca se cumplió no entonces hay muchas
quejas desde este tipo ahora la pandemia
también ha evidenciado el débil sistema
de salud en el cuadro del país está
preparado para una
nueva aula de puntajes
y no quiero entrar en subjetividades yo
creería que deberíamos estar preparados
pero aparentemente hemos saturado las
terapias intensivas nuevamente a pesar
de que tuvimos varios meses de calma en
la costa y varios meses de calma en la
sierra todavía estamos luchando por
tener camas de terapia intensiva
entonces definitivamente yo creo que la
preparación y la planificación de el
ente regulador de salud ha sido escasa y
pues definitivamente no creo que hemos
estado preparados para esta segunda ola
a nivel de la que la estamos viviendo no
doctor ortiz gracias por su tiempo por
estar aquí con nosotros en france24
feliz resto de noche